français en chine une forte de
l'expérience de l'épidémie de sras ce de
l'an dernier des mesures draconiennes
sont prises ont été prises pour abattre
les volailles nous l'avons montré ces
derniers jours
interdiction également d'exporter des
poules une autre mesure plus discrète
mais bien réelle celle-là
l'interdiction de survol de la capitale
pékin par les pigeons philippe rochot
sylvain viaut reportage
chaque matin monsieur liu fait voler ses
pigeons mais depuis deux jours l'espace
est plutôt restreint
pékin vient d'interdire le vol des
pigeons sur la capitale et surtout
l'utilisation de pigeons voyageurs
un loisir apprécié en chine or voilà
cent ans que la famille de monsieur liu
fait voler ses pigeons sur pékin même
pendant le grand bond en avant où les
communistes vous l'êtes éliminer tous
les oiseaux
ses parents ont continué de les élever
ça n'est pas la grippe aviaire qui va
l'arrêter
et maintenant je n'ai peur d'aucune
maladie donc vous prenez des précautions
comme le nettoyage et la désinfection
des cages et que vous assurer que les
pigeons développe un bon système
immunitaire vous n'avez rien à craindre
monsieur liu n'élève pas moins de 500
pigeons sur ce toit et même s'il ne
croit pas aux dangers de la maladie il
respecte les consignes du gouvernement
il dépense 150 euros par mois pour les
nourrir
le salaire d'un employé mais il est sûr
qu'ils sont en bonne santé
les pigeons n'ont pas ce genre de
problèmes de santé
dans l'histoire il n'y a pas de cas
d'épidémie apportées par les pigeons les
poulets eux sont élevées en masse alors
que les pigeons grandissent par petit
nombre à différents endroits pour la
santé de ses pigeons monsieur liu ajoute
au grain une foudre sortie de la
médecine chinoise traditionnelle qui les
protégera contre l'épidémie
mais pour lui la peste des oiseaux a
toujours existé voilà un siècle qu'on en
parle et personne parmi ses amis ou sa
famille n'a jamais rien attraper